I'm happy being from New York and I'm
single I know well it's hard being
single when you look like you're seven
years old like I talk to women but they
never take me serious because they
always think I'm just some black kid
trying to sell candy for his basketball
team like I'm what I try not to be -
whoa and if you're older here and you
don't know what whop means it basically
means you see the glass is half empty or
half full of water and I see it as Flint
still doesn't have clean water like I'm
conscious I have my boy to talk to
masculinity I got one of those homie
that's like yeah I'm a man I'm a man
look oh you have to do is be a good
person don't say like it was his
birthday I got him a cake I was at your
happy birthday but he was I he's such a
man he's a wife give me this cake you
think I like cakes or something
but I saw the twinkle in his eye the
twinkle in his eye thank you so much
[Applause]
it's like just cry
it's fellas you have to cry if you don't
cry you gonna kill somebody like I'm not
only heterosexual black man who has gay
friends I'm tracking my boys brilliant
horizon cuz I gave people a dope I'll
tell you one thing they have a better
time on Instagram my gamers name is on
Instagram they went pumpkin picking I
wanna go I can't get my straight friends
to go pumpkin picking yo Trey let's go
pumpkin pick it's gonna be any girls
there why does that have to be the
objective
let's just go we looking some iron shake
he takes him so he's got like some that
ain't no girls aren't going oh that's
your only premise that's tax and
masculine ease premise get girls get
drunk get girls get drunk you don't one
time my boys at yo let's go a little uh
sure concert I'm like wow we don't like
Usher he's like nah but there's gonna be
mad girls there yeah but they never for
us are they not there for us
what type of logic is that hey girl you
can't get him to look at me
like I'm conscious on hip-hop like a
love hip-hop but we all know sometimes
as a misogynist again I think it's cuz
of the male ego like I don't like when
rappers like yo I stole your girl no you
didn't I was wack and she went to you
stop back like she and walk over there
she has legs it takes away a woman's
choice like if you stole my girl that's
kidnapping that's a whole of the song I
gotta listen to the song for the ransom
got your girl in the club 50 grit
julissa you out there please hit me back
on the gram I don't know where you went
I don't know which migos took up look
I'm not political but I do worry about
this country's uprising white supremacy
and as a black man I'm not even angry
I'm just exhausted I'm like what do they
want what do they want but you lost a
long time ago just let diversity in just
let love and diversity and cuz I'm not
going back I have too many sneakers I'm
not going back
anonymous shipping with cost I put all
my sneakers on the cargo ship to Africa
then they get lost at sea now I'm in
Africa with loafers I'm not doing that
I'm wearing my Easy's here look and I
don't hate them because they want that
divide between us we all the same they
want that divide no look I know this
country is built on 500 years of
oppression he built this country's
wealth for free slavery but I would walk
around freaking white supremacy freaking
white people no I just don't believe in
paying back student loans that's it
that's my reparations every time they
hit me up I just put cotton ball in the
envelopes in the right to him did you
get my payment I got more cotton keep
calling me from a number I recognized
I'd say more once I figure out the venmo
Kyle it's a wreck
you